pour flavio le fourmilier c'est l'heure
du petit déjeuner flavio vient tout
juste d'arriver sur le bassin d'arcachon
en provenance d'un zoo allemand dans le
cadre d'un échange d'animaux destinés à
préserver ces espèces menacées c'est un
petit mâle fourmilier qui âgé d'un an et
qui est ici en fait qu'on vue de
reproduction enfin pour le programme
d'élevage des familiers donc il arrive
en premier il y aura une femelle qu'il
rejoindra l'année prochaine à chaque
fois qu'on essaie d'avoir telle ou telle
espèce on s'adresse aux coordonnateurs
qui lui va nous donner des animaux qui
sont disponibles dans d'autres parcs
zoologiques donc c'est en fait sous ses
formes des chambres constituent la
collection qu'on fait partir aussi des
animaux qui se perd sur plus de 800
animaux d'une centaine d'espèces vivent
dans les eaux du bassin d'arcachon les
deux tiers ont été acquis grâce aux
échanges qui permettent de diversifier
le capital génétique les tapirs mal et
nour et à 10 ou cézanne de somalie sont
les produits de ce programme européen
on a des âmes de somalie et on avait
jusqu alors en fait qu'un groupe de mal
et on a reçu une petite femelle à vous
voyez sur la gauche là qui s'appelle
ginger une femelle d'un an qui est voué
à reproduire dans notre réseau avec l'un
d'eux normal du coup bah en fait le mal
qui avec elle va devoir partir du coup
dans quinze jours au zoo de liberec en
république tchèque
menacés dans leur milieu naturel les
pensionnaires des eaux sont aujourd'hui
de grands voyageurs chaque année
l'automne est la période des transferts
pour la faune destiné à être préservé en
captivité les animaux aussi ont leur
mercato